las escuelas de afganistán volvieron a
recibir a sus estudiantes en esta
escuela secundaria en kabul los alumnos
se ven de nuevo luego de que los
talibanes se tomaran la capital hace más
de un mes y la situación obligará a
cerrar todos los centros educativos
nuestra ambición y nuestro sueño es
empezar de nuevo a estudiar y también
queremos que empiece de nuevo porque los
talibanes no son tan violentos como
antes
espero que todo vuelva a la normalidad
solo matado trabajando a mejoras
incorporadas ojos pero en esta escuela
las mujeres no tienen lugar y por ahora
tampoco lo tienen en las escuelas
secundarias que son para mujeres como
obliga la ley islámica bajo la cual
gobierna el régimen talibán sin embargo
en los centros de educación primaria las
niñas pudieron volver a clases en aulas
segregadas
y por ahora no tenemos ningún problema
en nuestra escuela los horarios son
diferentes para niños y niñas las niñas
estudian por la mañana y los niños por
la tarde los maestros enseñan a los
chicos y las maestras a las niñas
en el pasado cuando los talibanes
controlaron afganistán de 1996 a 2001
las menores tenían prohibido acudir a la
escuela aunque ahora en muchas partes
del país está permitida la educación
primaria de las menores estas no podrán
acceder a estudios más avanzados ni
realizar trabajos fuera de casa la
agencia de la onu para la infancia
celebro la reapertura de las aulas sin
embargo se mostró profundamente
preocupada de que muchas de las menores
afganas siguen siendo obligadas a
quedarse en casa